[Music]
oh
what's up you guys keep sniffling he's
like stop sniffling
why don't you stop breathing how about
that
[Laughter]
why am i [ __ ] going off the screen i
don't know the damn screen
why is it so dark in here why is it so
dark in here yeah
what's going on what's going on what's
up with this see there you go
[Laughter]
this is some weird action it's like
we're only five seconds into the show
check the ball you know you already
should play [ __ ] up the volume too
yeah it was all the all the way up when
i checked it before but i fixed it
okay so hopefully [ __ ] poker guys
send this [ __ ]
i'm telling you right now i'll check
right now i'm checking
okay i'm checking right now see how i'm
checking check that [ __ ]
i'm checking it i'm checking it wait a
minute device properties
okay so there we go it's fine it's fine
yeah just hopefully
it won't i want to know why this is my
normal place over here and look
i'm [ __ ] off the damn screen well
what do you want like i said i think he
comes in here and moves the camera
that's probably what it is because she
comes in here and climbs around
and bites on things because she likes to
chew on metal for whatever
what it is it doesn't make any goddamn
sense yeah because i didn't touch it was
space is the space time continuum being
warped or something there's a black hole
in the in the area
and things are getting closer together
the spaces in which things that occupy
are getting closer together
moving without movement that kind of
[ __ ] a black hole in this office would
explain a lot actually yeah
the hell dj maniac says because pookie
has an only fan she hasn't told you to
about yet
he's in here while we're sleeping
filming herself feeling herself laying
on her belly
i put a whole bunch of sexy [ __ ]
videos and pictures of our
jenny and all our friends and [ __ ] i had
that put that up on instagram
the other day got a lot of reactions
from people shared some of them yeah
that was from the uh halfway to
halloween party that we went to after
the aileen warno's show
yeah jenny dressed up like the bride of
frankenstein
i'm blutting her blouse boobs hanging
out and [ __ ] [ __ ] little restaurant
i was trying to eat my chicken and
waffles actually before the food came
and he's like trying to [ __ ] [ __ ]
them yeah they said
the buttons survived the night and said
i made sure they did yeah the guy was
like good job
that's how you do it yeah [ __ ] right
well i think one of them actually had
come undone without me
noticing because then we were talking to
this girl and she told me that it was
undone and i was like oh yeah yeah
walking in our friend aurora was there
she was going to do suspension gig she
does a nice
dance for the camera and [ __ ] [ __ ]
shows her ass off and then later on
[ __ ]
they stick hooks through her back and
[ __ ] she's swinging through the
[ __ ]
swinging through the sky yeah damn truth
they did that on the back
patio yeah and some other girl too these
[ __ ] industrial girls
all tatted up and [ __ ] it was a pretty
big turnout gotta say
yeah pretty good turnout pretty good i
don't know i don't remember who won the
costume contest because i think i was
outside when that was going on
that cat yeah did your cat i don't
know the neighbors uh kid or their dog
it's kind of hard it was both they well
yeah they have a dog that barks and then
they have a little girl that goes
yeah yeah like all the time like
everything like every time the top part
she goes
yeah it's like really funny yeah sleep
says hooks yeah they were hooks man
yeah yeah yeah it was a
it was a good total it was a fun night
like i said then we went to chantel's
and i got some chicken and waffles
yeah i couldn't eat it all though it was
like a massive
the chicken was real good it was really
good it wasn't over salted
like the fish was last week yeah we
didn't have like they did have some
salty uh catfish
last time that's well that's why i got
chicken and waffles this time even
though i think i maybe only ate half of
it it's a massive
it was like three big pieces of fried
chicken on this big huge waffle
okay go ahead and press the like button
people everybody likes
my [ __ ] right now talking about the new
creep show episode that came out just uh
touching base with it i thought it was
pretty good
yeah this was a pretty good one what i
didn't realize i wasn't sure
um because i was recording a show with
uh
the podcast wearing the folk and we got
to talking about that
and um that that guy on there had just
watched it as well
and uh i said i think i heard this was
the finale even though it's only the
fifth one
and i guess it was now they are gonna do
a season three that's already been
uh that's already been okayed like
nicotero came out and said that
that they'd already been okay to do a
season three so it is going to continue
i think what ended up happening was that
because the first season had
seven episodes yeah now this one i think
was also supposed to have seven episodes
but what ended up happening was that
because it got delayed they wanted to do
um something over last christmas so they
took one of the episodes from the season
and made that the christmas special
and then i think there was supposed to
be another episode but like marilyn
manson was in it and i think
like he just got a key like a bunch of
rape accusations and stuff so they were
like man maybe we shouldn't show that
one
or maybe we shouldn't do it or whatever
wait hold on hold on one second
what rape alex alligator i think so yeah
i don't know that much about it
that this is that's i'm already i'm
already tripping
because back in the 90s when he first
arrived that was his whole act that was
his whole gig
i mean he tells a story about how behind
backs behind backstage before some show
a fan brought him some dude who wanted
to be fisted
and his buddy said well his buddies in
the band says well you got to do it you
said you'd do anything
so they kept throwing [ __ ] [ __ ] at
him
that to make him do it because he had
once both well
like he would do anything and
and he in a perversion you know weird
perversions and [ __ ] was his [ __ ]
trademark
all on the back of that damn boast that
he made
but that's not the same thing as as uh
rape or like abusing your
girlfriends which is from what the
allegations were okay
yeah it didn't have anything okay
because there was all kinds you know
there was all well yeah everybody knows
that
yeah that's not what they're talking
about they're they're talking about like
some non-consensual [ __ ] and
beating the crap out of some of the
girlfriends they're talking about that
so so i guess he was
in one or was going to be in one and
they didn't show it
um so and then one of the ones was
carried over like they showed that last
christmas because they wanted something
to show over christmas time
so that's why there's only five this
time now i don't know
if one of the stories because this
episode which is the finale
is only one story because normally
they're two so i don't know if it was
set out
that it was only supposed to be one
story or if it was supposed to be two
and then they cut the other one i don't
know
but so yeah so this one is actually
called um
what is the name of it is called night
of the living late show yeah
which is a little it's a weird title
because when you think late show you
think like conan o'brien or
david letterman or what whoever the [ __ ]
is on does
late night talk shows now um but it's
not that
so it's basically this dude who named
simon and he's played by
justin long who you said he was familiar
that's because he was in tusk
okay uh he was in jeepers creepers he's
been in a ton of other [ __ ] too but um
that's probably where you recognize him
from
yeah he was in tusk so he plays this
inventor you're presuming and he has
invented
this thing it's it's obviously a tanning
bed but
it's like a vr machine where you can get
in there and you can
install yourself into pretty much any
movie that you want to
put yourself into and it's just like
being in the real environment except
it's in the movie right
so he's invented that and his favorite
movie in all the land
is horror express the 1972 film
starring christopher lee peter cushing
and telly cevallos
which actually might be on shutter in
its entirety i feel like it's kind of
like a forgotten
movie a little bit maybe this episode
will get more people to
get more people to watch it because i
like that movie a lot
but um so that's his favorite movie
one of the reasons being that well one
because it was the first one that his
dad took him to like the first grown-up
movie
and two because he's always had the hots
ever since he was a kid for the chick
that played the countess in the movie
right so i think the whole point of him
going into the movie was to try and get
with the countess
inside the movie so that's essentially
what he does now he's also married to
this woman named renee
and renee is they haven't been married
that long right because i think they
have a conversation which has been less
than a year or something like that so it
hasn't been that long a time but you
find out later that
it's possible that simon just married
renee for her
money uh because he wanted money to fund
his invention
[ __ ] and she's maybe kind of
questioning her decision to marry him
now because he's spending all her money
and
he's going into the movie to
make the move on the countess you know
what i mean
yeah so it's interesting because this is
why i asked if maybe this was supposed
to be
shorter because they use a lot of
footage
from horror express and also from night
of the living dead like at the end i
know that's in the public domain i'm
assuming horror express is also in the
public domain because they use so much
of it
and it so it almost seems a little bit
like i really did like this episode but
it did seem like
they use a lot of footage from that
movie almost like they were trying to
like pat it out to make it longer you
know what i'm saying
yeah did you get that vibe kind of a
little bit i like this one though this
is one of the better episodes i thought
so too
it's more movie-like it's not real gory
it's not gory it's more like a
psychological
there's also not a lot of content to it
i mean it's a very simple
premise yeah at least it was visual yeah
you know i thought it was cool
he was step he was in a vr experience
with
inside a movie i thought i thought it
was pretty neat so set up a good tone
i think i'd rather have one good episode
than two half-assed episodes now
now though that's true seeing this you
know i'm talking about
some of those half episodes are kind of
half-assed too
yeah it's kind of well the thing about
it is that i don't know
because some stories work better as
really short
really short other ones whereas some of
them you need you know
40 minutes you need an hour to tell like
the whole story
the only thing i might say about this
one because i you know as i said yes it
seemed like a lot of footage from night
of the living dead and a lot of
footage from horror express was used but
that didn't really bother me that much
because i always liked horror express so
i'm just kind of like it's kind of neat
seeing like
being him incorporated into the the old
movie t
showed up i uh posted a bunch of
videos on my instagram of me and jenny
[ __ ] around at night club with
friends of ours and stuff
and um and aurora being suspended
by hooks that's good that that was
pretty good one too her and her friend
so uh i don't know i know you don't you
claim not to have social media but if
you find
13 o'clock on um
instagram it will probably lead to my
instagram too just thomas ross and i got
them all put up there
and you uh you can check them out yeah
they're fun
they might be on my uh actually they're
on my uh
facebook also oh okay well then yeah
because i had them linked
so they should be up there too
yeah it goes well yeah you said it went
to both they're linked yeah right
i'm getting comments on both oh okay
yeah uh
the videos of your boobs and [ __ ] have
been a hit and videos of [ __ ] aurora
dancing and showing her ass what
was it well obviously and girls
getting comments from my brazilian
friends brazilian bikers and [ __ ] going
hell yeah
and army and ex-army rangers and stuff
well there and dunham from uh
uh what what's is it from um a haunting
he was he was in one of the episodes
from haunting
he made a comment he was like wow man
you know you and your crowd you know
he [ __ ] wants to hang out well he
lives it he lives
right here yeah yeah we saw him he was
working uh working up the street he's
one dude who talks a lot of [ __ ] but
never goes anywhere though just stays up
in the house a lot of people do
he's like though he's like yeah yeah i
got to do that no i never
hang out that dude never comes out
sitting around watching tv
[ __ ] gaining weight like i said he
only lives right here he lives right
around here
like not even that only like a mile or
two from us right yeah are he used to
used to i don't know where he lives now
oh okay so yeah that was a while back
yeah he's from uh he had an episode in
like
season one or two of a haunting and it
was called a haunting in daytona right
no it was deltona delton well it was
called the haunting in florida hunting
in florida
but it was deltona which is between
daytona and orlando
yeah and that that that's about that's
about him that's a good it's a good
episode
that's how i met him i [ __ ] talked to
him first online
and then i went down to the hardware
store to go get something and the guy's
helping me [ __ ] pick out nuts and
bolts and [ __ ]
to build this [ __ ] fuel motor i was
working on at the time and i turned on
cuz dude you look real familiar and i go
you're ed dunham
because yeah because you you from from
haunted because yeah yes i talked to you
i talked to you on the phone and online
yeah yeah
yeah he's an ex-rv raider he's from a
ranger bat
yeah 75th yeah his house was honored
yeah his house was haunted
that was a good idea actually saw a dude
sitting on it sitting on his [ __ ] bed
smoking a cigar
he was all wet and filthy and [ __ ] he
goes get out of this house get out of
here
he thought it was a real person dude
stood up and vanished
and then he could hear somebody walking
through walking across the top of the
[ __ ]
roof and uh they ran out of that house
[ __ ] left all their belongings behind
it was pretty good story
he swears up and down that it happened i
don't doubt him man i [ __ ] had my
poultry guys to experience
but his was ghost his was haunting it
wasn't poltergeist
but it had poltergeist elements his his
kids saw it too
she had a couple of sons and a wife at
that time i think he's got more kids now
more wives
more kids more wise yeah a whole house
full of wine
and he left that he he broke up with
that wife
i think they were even broken up when
they did the show when they did the show
they were kind of on the
on the outside yeah uh dom the bomb says
hey here's something i didn't know
horror express was based
on the short story used to make the
thing movies so i guess who goes there
that's the name of that story
i did not realize that actually but yeah
now that you say that i can
i could see it but uh but yeah so this
was actually a good episode i think
somebody pointed out greg nicotero
directed it as um you know he directed a
lot of the other ones too
this was written by dana gould who
actually um
i knew him [ __ ] man i used to see his
stand-up because he used to be stand-up
comedian
he used to be on comedy central all the
time like back in the 90s
and then he went into uh
screenwriting and [ __ ] like that so i
think
he might have written he wrote some
other [ __ ] too and i remember he starred
in one of the episodes of creep show
from the first season
the one that was called skin crawlers
like the one about the
uh that diet clinic that you ate the
you know the the parasite yeah and it
like ate all your fat
yeah yeah he was in that one there's
another way to do that though
uh well duh obviously but that's kind of
like what it is
he's all into that yeah yeah you inject
something and all of a sudden
you've eaten the tape worms yeah but
that that was a good episode i just
rewatched that one not too long ago and
i was like wow that was like really
disgusting i loved it
inject that test you start sweating out
that bacon grease
tila loves it when i was talking about
bacon grease so gross
yeah i'm going to go change the bed
sheets and my side of the [ __ ] sheets
were [ __ ]
great ray oil
i don't have to watch the sides look
[ __ ] clean my side was just around
yeah because i'm not because i'm not
like disgusting
right now i'm not like a disgusting
phil's pollock you are
[Laughter]
it's chemically induced well that
doesn't make it anything much better
no see he does that all the time he was
doing that he was doing that to me at
mannequins that night too and he was
like
because he was like all kind of like
greasy and he's like touch it down he's
like [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] yeah you look so greasy
[Laughter]
i'm like then i have to go wash my hands
i don't want to [ __ ] do that
just [ __ ] you don't have to burn fat
when you just sweat it out
i guess yeah or you know if you remember
remember back in the
i guess it was maybe the 90s remember
when they had that [ __ ] what the hell
was that stuff called
that um uh it was like a fat substitute
that they put in everything
yeah the [ __ ] the game that gave you
yeah yeah yeah
olestra that's what it was called i knew
it was i knew it was something like that
uh olestra and it would give you like
like anal leakage
like that was one of the yeah so like
all the fat was coming out of your butt
yeah it just comes out of your [ __ ]
skin tom was trying to do grease
wrestling scentsy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you people you brought it up [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
it's just she she was making fun you
look so greasy and i said you did
yeah i did but i look [ __ ] good
though i couldn't tell in the dark
well it wasn't well i didn't notice
until we went outside we went out there
we went out
we went up front that [ __ ] light was
shining because we were talking about
ourselves
straight from [ __ ] omega man shine
the body
died yeah
it's just a natural biological process
sure that that's that's your story and
you're sticking to it
yeah hey man
you start seeing that [ __ ] six-pack
now
you wait for a couple more months jenny
okay you're gonna be jealous of that
six-pack
not really i don't know
[Laughter]
do what i'm [ __ ] chipping dale's
dancing like that you're gonna see
you have an active fantasy it's gonna
break
it's gonna break it's gonna bring no
it's gonna bring that those [ __ ]
urges out of you
okay i have to buy a fireman outfit
my gladiator costume put that [ __ ] on
yeah i like that i like the gladiator
idea though yeah
that'd be kind of funny oh yeah i want
to see you in a skirt yeah
leather one greaves and [ __ ] yeah
yeah shield and the [ __ ] helmet dress
up like a goddamn mermillo
or something yeah it was like yeah
yeah uh dj maniac says dana gold was
also the showrunner for the simpsons for
a while oh i didn't know that
uh pat hatfield said skin crawlers was
my favorite episode from season one
yeah when i re-watched some of season
one not too long ago and i had forgotten
how
[ __ ] great that episode was it was
just so so good
um yeah karen rob says this stuff man we
need to review that
that is that is such a ridiculous movie
that's just [ __ ] ridiculous it is
ridiculous
i remember seeing it back in god back
when it first came out like back in the
80s
yeah on cable and i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i watching um
it was it was [ __ ] crazy back then
but
well it's a satire yeah that that movie
played real well back in the 80s
you know especially for its time and and
for a young audience of that time
because it was just like it was a satire
of the whole
horror monster movie thing yeah it was
kind of like the blob but it was also
it was also making fun of the health
industry
yeah and also like corporate propaganda
that too and all kinds of stuff
yeah advertising campaigns and [ __ ] it
was just
it was cool it was cool yeah we didn't
have
internet so you didn't have a bunch of
nerds sitting picking things apart
so if something kind of sucked a little
bit you didn't really get negative input
you
the online community could not turn you
against something like they can do it
now
so you saw everything you saw was like
in isolation or you saw it with you and
your friends and if your friends liked
it then you liked it
and we did not look too deeply into
things it was just very superficial [ __ ]
it all
came and went pretty quickly every every
month there was more of them
so you know there was only some of them
that were classically kept going back to
like all the [ __ ] reanimator ones and
the from beyond ones all the stuff with
jeffrey columbus we'd watch that a lot
i mean you gotta love jeffrey yeah
jeffrey cohen i'll watch him and then
we watch him a lot tila said i've never
seen this stuff is that cronenberg no
it's actually larry cohen uh the same
guy that did it's alive the killer baby
movie uh
cue the winged serpent yeah god told me
to which i think we reviewed
it was that guy it's crazy it's freaky
it's pretty crazy it's funny but yeah
it's like a comedy but
it's all practical effects it's kind of
like the blob
yeah man we need to do the remake of the
blob too because i really really liked
that
camp guy says there is a funny essay on
the net about side effects of whatever
they called that fat
ain't that electrical yeah that kind of
i don't know why but that just reminded
me of the
of the classic set of uh reviews for
those
sugar-free gummy bears that everyone was
saying like gave them the
apocalyptic shits oh my god so funny
yeah the gummy bear
the chicken government because it's got
that it's got that sugar substitute in
it that is kind of like a laxative
and i guess if you eat a lot of them
you'll uh you'll regret it
i haven't tried them i haven't either
that's just what i've heard i'd be
willing to take that experiment
i'm sure you would yeah
he'll just he'll eat a five pound bag of
sugar-free gummy bears and then he'll be
in the bathroom
like screaming for like several hours
that would be really funny
look at amanda just said holy [ __ ] i'm
cleaning my house while watching this
and i just found a bag with almost 500
in it oh [ __ ] you're rich first i never
keep cash
second how does one not notice 500
missing i wonder where that came from
one of your friends must have pulled it
over there it's not yours it's somebody
who knows you
maybe the poltergeist lost her drug
money
[Laughter]
couldn't go to the law to add task about
i lost 500 bucks
where where'd you get the money from why
i can't answer that question
i'm pleading the fifth on that officer
uh dj maniac apocalyptic shits i think i
did a show with them
that should be a band name right yeah
team's always adding things to her list
and then half the time she never gets
back with us because she never watches
it
well the thing about look i have a list
too but it's like
and every time i look um you know on all
the streaming services we have
because i look every week like for new
movies to put into the polls or whatever
and it's like every i'm like oh they
added that oh they added that one oh no
and it's like then i have to add that to
the list i have like 40 bajillion movies
on that list
and i was saying today i said i'm never
going to live long enough to watch all
this gee see
uh repo genetic opera and get back with
us you're going to like that one
if you like music i've been wanting to
review that one actually we need to
review that we can do that on uh one of
the bad days i guess if we didn't uh get
around to it yeah
but uh but yeah camp guy said one rule
was carry brown clothes with you and
extra change at all times
brown clothes ew do you remember like
back in the old days they used to have
this really funny
commercials for laxatives i can't
remember which lacks it was in dulca lax
or
i don't know what it was but i just
remember
uh the tagline was you never know where
where you'll be when your blackstone
starts working and they show like this
sad dude like sitting in a rowboat like
out in the middle of the [ __ ] ocean
or whatever and he just looks at the
camera and he's like oh that's like for
some reason that used to like really
just make me laugh
where where where right there uh
tom have you watched sisters yet let's
make a deal watch that and i'll watch
repo
which one was sister the brian de palma
one actually you know what
um i am gonna watch that either today or
tomorrow
because i'm gonna do a uh uh flickers of
fear on it which one is sisters
it's brian de palma marcus meaning margo
kidder isn't it
okay she plays it's from the 70s okay
she plays i've seen it before
but it's been like several years it's a
horror movie yeah
okay like a horror thriller okay yeah
kind of like as she plays twins
okay oh [ __ ] i'll love that that's got
two margo kidders in it it's two
two margot kidders yeah well that one
was just she was just
yeah since i was a kid they're just
something [ __ ] about her [ __ ] and
attractive
when i was a little kid i was like
i can't understand it i wouldn't even
[ __ ] it wouldn't even you know
seven eight years old nine years old you
know i hadn't even hit puberty and i'd
see [ __ ] women like margo kidder and
[ __ ] i was trying to get that i was like
man i wish i could have that
yeah it's on um like i said i added it
to my flickers of fear thing because
uh shutter has it but the uk shutter has
it so you have to like go through the
vpn
yeah you know what i mean and you can
watch it on there although maybe we can
find it somewhere else like on amazon
prime or something i just saw that um
i just saw that shutter uk had it but
we'll see if you want to watch it with
me you can watch it
all right you can even do review with it
if you want to i don't care
but uh yeah so what were you talking
about okay so we were talking about
creep show like i said this is a good
finale um seemed like it seemed like
like i said they used a lot of footage
from
uh from horror express and it almost
seemed like they were trying to make it
longer
also i kind of wish they had done like a
little bit more
um maybe a little bit more character
development because it did seem kind of
strange that they'd been married for a
year
and his wife didn't really uh
know what he was working on or didn't
really notice it nice house in that
[ __ ] [ __ ] though
i like the indoor pools yeah they're
saying it's a story about a good twin
and a bad twin
yeah and i guess they're both hotties
that kind of reminds me of
i dream of genie remember how genie had
an evil twin
you know that with the dark hair what
was her name somebody might remember
oh i feel like i know that and then they
would try to impersonate each other
and and uh jeannie's evil twin would
show up she had
she had black hair or brown instead wore
green
yeah that's right but then she would she
would impersonate
genie that was some fun and the same
thing happened on bewitched
there that sam had a [ __ ] didn't
didn't somebody impersonate samantha
same way i don't remember yeah i haven't
seen a lot but b which was always trying
to rip off
g i dream of jeannie yeah louie said
that was bewitched
bewitched but did i no they did it on
both shows
oh did they get it on both sides i don't
remember i haven't seen this since i was
a kid
yep well that that's a pretty common
thing like the the good evil twin trope
yeah i kind of feel like that going back
to [ __ ] the parent trap or whatever
you know with uh haley mills yeah
notice they always make the bad one with
dark hair yeah they do
they do well the um black out white hat
this was back in the day back in the day
where you know what i mean like and you
know the ideal
[ __ ] ideal white wife
was [ __ ] blonde blonde hair blue eyes
i kind of wanted that
aryan nordic look to them that was like
the ideal
so of course you know what i mean now
it's not saying that [ __ ] you know
dark-haired brunette is not attractive
also they knew
that it's just that they were they were
trying to appeal to middle america
middle america was blonde hair blue eyed
wannabes
most of them were [ __ ] died well died
blonde
but you know that was that was that was
in style though
pat said pandora's box was the character
from bewitched
okay pandora pandora
yeah yeah that's right pandora it sounds
right
yeah that sounds like the name that they
have that they would give her i think
you're right because you know pandora's
box and all that i remember those
remember the shows as being fun i'd like
to see them again they're probably
annoying as hell to watch now
you never know they might have held up
really well i don't know like i said i
haven't seen them since i was a kid so i
don't really know anytime i go back and
watch old television from the 80s even
the 90s
it's almost unwatchable because it's
just so formulaic
and so canned it feels very artificial
compared to just people on youtube
youtube i think
was started with reality tv came
that was an improvement even though it
wasn't reality yeah and then youtube
became like the ultimate reality shows
and it just seems a lot better
you go back and you watch some people i
was analyzing some of the performances
by [ __ ]
great actors and stuff and performers
and it's such so obviously a false
theatrical performance
it does kind of get on you
you know what i mean it seems very
artificial in fact almost like you're
looking at kabuki
yeah or old opera well acting styles
come and go
come and go yeah i mean obviously i
think the reason why a lot of people
can't really hang with
really old movies like from the 20s 30s
40s was because they were still
carryover from live theater yeah so
everything was just
big gestures and like big you know
everything was kind of overdone
and then when kind of the 60s and 70s
came along you got more you're like
cinema verite like more of a realistic
yeah like people were trying to act like
yeah the original people
started to look really out of date you
know very quickly
like i love old star trek but that those
acting styles are very
out of style yeah you don't see that
anymore
unless someone's parodying it right
yeah i mean now it seems like an actor
is trying to
vanish into the role is trying to be
that role they're not trying to you know
what i mean
what was weird is that star trek the
original series
was so different from star trek the
movies
with william shatner and everything the
tone was very different but they were
able to to modernize it it did work
yeah you know i mean the acting styles
were very different
yeah fourth row down just said i've
watched reruns of mash and the canned
laughter is
intolerable yeah yeah i really wish they
hadn't done that because i really think
it kind of ruins the experience
i mean i'm sure somebody out there has
taken like good shows from the past and
taken the laugh track out i would hope
yeah yeah like i would dare you to try
to sit through an episode of three's
company
i bet it's probably unwatchable i tried
to watch an episode of uh
all in the family and just couldn't i
was like oh no i can't take this
same thing laugh tracks and just what we
consider be bad acting and bad writing
kind of they
even though i had fond memories of it
but you go back and watch it it's just
it's intolerable well you everything is
very
like you said formulaic and everything
is obviously you know like a setup
for a joke you know i mean it's not like
organic it doesn't flow really
organically
what aged well were the off-the-cuff
game shows
hollywood squares from the 70s those are
still fun
[Laughter]
the liars club that's still funny it's
on there
and it's because that was like the
beginning of reality tv
you know they were obviously drunk doing
those [ __ ] shows
and they're drinking and [ __ ] they'd cut
to some dude and you could see him
hiding his glass
and [ __ ] getting back to doing the
game show a chance oh what i'm back on
all right
how did that [ __ ] drink glass put
that not jen shut up yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] fun and then you hear the crowd
laughing the live crowd laughing
he hit his [ __ ] drake the [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious
[Laughter]
yeah that's a good shot buddy hacking
drunk off his ass on the liar's club
barely able to [ __ ] get out you're
barely able to [ __ ]
talk wow
that's what it is it's a gynecological
thing it goes up right now you know you
don't laugh
like that you know i wonder didn't even
remember vomit on the show when they had
like just discreetly kind of like look
over the side
they record a bunch of them at once and
they couldn't stay sober all that time
yeah i think they did like four episodes
a day or something well they do maybe
more i think they still do that like
with
with shorter game shows like jeopardy
and [ __ ] like that i think they'd do
four of those a day like they filmed
four of them a day yeah so you know guys
like buddy hacking and [ __ ]
what's his name [ __ ] paul lind and
[ __ ] hollywood squares man i'm gonna
keep them so
you weren't gonna be able to keep them
sober all that time they're like what i
have to sit here for like six hours yeah
yeah
without a drink [ __ ] that yeah i know
that feeling it was the 70s man
i kind of feel like that too it's like
[ __ ] i was like if i'm gonna sit here
and watch two movies like
you can damn well bet i'm gonna drink
well um oh i wanted to say too it's
just apropos nothing i also started
watching shutter just added
um not only the new the finale of group
show but they also just added in search
of darkness
part two which of you guys i think we
reviewed the first one
and it's a it's a whole it's a massively
uh long documentary about
80s horror and the first one was really
really good and i started watching the
second one last night and i was watched
about
i don't even think i got to that i got
like two hours in and i was like okay
i'm falling asleep i can't watch the
whole thing because i'd watch something
else beforehand
um but yeah i definitely want to watch
the rest of that too because
i love that they're talking about they
started talking about like lesser known
because this is the second one
they can talk about like kind of lesser
known movies from the 80s because i feel
like
you know the first one they kind of
covered all the big uh you know all the
all the big ticket ones and all the
trends that were going on in the 80s and
talked to like about all the special
effects and [ __ ]
they talked to tom savini and whatnot
but this one they can kind of focus
a little bit more on lesser-known
examples of the genres you know what i
mean so they're talking about like
um you know they talked about some of
lucio folgi's stuff
they talked about uh inferno they talked
about dead and buried they talked about
um evil speak for christ's sake which
which we reviewed
um you know so so it's cool that you
know humanoids from the deep i think i'm
trying to think of some other ones that
they
i that i was kind of surprised that they
covered mother's day
um so i think i'm only i'm at 83 because
it goes like
it does like each year and then they
talk about a selection of movies that
came out that year like trends that were
going on in that year
and i think i made it up to 1983 or
maybe 1984
and uh then i had to stop because i was
falling asleep but i definitely want to
watch the rest of that at some point
louis vuitton louie chimes in and said
yep tom's right don't watch shows you
liked as a kid nothing good can come of
it
um somebody mentioned that um
what was it um morticia
adams had a twin sister who's supposed
to be the good
sister but then tina says yeah but you
notice that
the bad one the bad scene is always
super memorable
yeah yeah there's something to that
because the bad girl's usually sexier
yeah like i preferred the [ __ ] bad
version of genie
yeah she's a lot naughtier she's kind of
a 60 second
cool chick you know she's trying to get
[ __ ] pants and [ __ ] i like that
better
well yeah i mean well it's always going
to be more fun to hang out with somebody
right yeah a little bit right look got
some spice yeah
and that that'll go out and do fun yeah
yeah fun bad [ __ ] with you
yeah and then amanda talks about carol
burnett's show it's loaded with left
tracks yeah
it was it was it was still funny though
i got it there yeah carol burnett was
super funny
it seemed to be at the time i haven't
watched it me and my grandma used to
watch it all the time
yeah i haven't seen it in a long time i
have no idea what it was i imagined
shows like the love boat and fantasy
island are now totally unwatchable
i kind of wonder every now and then i
kind of get
every now and then i kind of get kind of
an idea that i should watch like an old
fantasy island because i remember some
of those being like kind of creepy
what like someone were like yeah and i
was kind of like maybe i should go back
and watch it especially after we watched
that blum house
yeah fantasy island i was like maybe i
should go back and watch some of the old
shows and see what they're like
we saw that one in the theater i was
mildly entertained
but right i heard somebody say that
there's a longer edit of it that they
released on on blu-ray they said it's a
lot better
well i imagine because it does seem like
it was pg-13 wasn't it yeah okay so
there's probably like a lot of gore that
they took out
yeah i kind of i imagine it's better
that's kind of what they do if
i feel like if blumhouse if they try to
if they have to compromise by releasing
a pg-13 into the theater for a wider
audience
then later they can also release a
blu-ray that has the longer cut with all
the gore on it and everybody's happy
you know what i mean maybe louise louie
hernandez says remember kitt's evil twin
car i don't remember that i don't know i
didn't i didn't watch
i saw some of them but i didn't see the
whole i didn't see the whole run
yeah andy warhol once appeared on the
love boat i thought i vaguely i
vaguely remember that i'm sure that was
a probably a pretty surreal episode
yeah that dude was so [ __ ] weird
[Laughter]
now i got to to youtube i'm gonna go
[ __ ] check that out now
all right yeah pat says who says love
boat and fantasy island were watchable
when they were new
uh they were watching when you were a
kid love boat was pretty insufferable
even back then
i liked fantasy islands i watched them
as a kid when they were when
when they came out but i also watched
six million dollar man
and i also watched [ __ ] bionic
bigfoot and loved it so
i'm not saying much you know man [ __ ]
bionic bigfoot
and it turned out buying it yeah well it
turned out
bigfoot was bionic you didn't know that
at the time
you just see six million dollar man
confronting bigfoot
and this is the time when sasquatch was
like a reality
for a kid oh there you know there's a
bigfoot that's because adults talked
about it yeah
so you know we were worried about
running into it even leonard namoy said
that there was some pictures
[ __ ] we've got a backyard middle [ __ ]
middle b
we'll be in the middle of long beach
california afraid that we might run into
bigfoot
oh well it's because we saw this bomb
and
we had this bomb that used to [ __ ]
walk down alameda all the best stories
start and then we saw this ball
there was this dude that we used to call
my parents used to call him
and everybody else on the block just
call him the alan meet a wild man
all right
i don't think i've heard this story yeah
my uh [ __ ] jackson street in [ __ ]
carson
ended at a place called uh alameda
boulevard
and on the other side of the boulevard
was a [ __ ] railroad track when it
fed all these industries that are
probably not there anymore
and this guy will walk down that [ __ ]
railroad track
up and down it all day long and they
called him the alameda wild man he
looked just like bigfoot
wow and he was we didn't know how old he
was he's evidently still alive
and this still called the alameda wild
man maybe he is bigfoot
he was young then we didn't know he was
young he just couldn't tell under all
the hair
under the hair and all that dirt okay he
was a white dude
all right but you couldn't tell because
he just [ __ ] caked on oil
all over his [ __ ] face like motor oil
with dirt on that because he was
sleeping up on train tracks
yeah all right and his hair was [ __ ]
went way
up here and his beard went all the way
down to here and he was wearing
just filthy [ __ ] army clothes
and he was a vietnam veteran it turned
out that's what he was
he when he had come back from vietnam
and said [ __ ] it and just lived on the
damn railroad tracks and he was on his
uh
wearing his army field jacket my dad
talked to him once
he was coherent but he was just [ __ ]
nuts
yeah he was rambo but we called him the
alameda wild man
and he's evidently still alive that's
crazy so
he my dad didn't know how old he was
but my mother's friend who lived on that
block is still alive my mother talked to
her recently
and she wants well you know this is in
the past couple of years and she
mentioned she told me that the alameda
wild man is still alive
and walks up and up and down alameda
boulevard
actually he's been doing that for that
many decades yeah still living down and
there
so he must be in his 70s
now but he's still alive and sometimes
you'd see him with a dog
and sometimes he wouldn't have a dog and
then sometimes he'd have another dog and
sometimes he'd have two dogs
sometimes the dogs would be on ropes so
he'd make little dog friends and [ __ ]
make little dog friends yeah i don't
know if he'd eat him or what but you
know him
jesus don't say that he had a dog friend
that was yelling at a while man lives
out in
carson you know you probably can then
drop it in the comment section tell me
the last time you saw the alameda wild
man
he looked like bigfoot now you need to
look that up on youtube because probably
somebody has been like filming him yeah
he looked like bigfoot
from uh six million dollar man
we saw him and [ __ ] freaked us out
that sounds cool yeah yeah like
sasquatch he looked huge to us we were
little kids
yeah but he was probably you know five
eight
if y'all if y'all had been on the ball
you could have made like a little
documentary about it
like like watching him from the bushes
like like a [ __ ] david attenborough
or something
we were over there we were over there
and had forgotten about him
and we and we were behind something and
came around and there he was
you know at a close range walking
towards us all right so we
just screamed and ran ran across rally
to the boulevard [ __ ] through the
traffic and [ __ ] and everything
but um no we used to see him from a
distance all the time
huh yeah so that's my story poor
stardown is talking about a six million
dollar man and he says i remember an
episode called death probe
which that's pretty funny right there in
which steve austin beat up a trash can
what
beat up a trash can it must have been it
must have been a a robot
a robot that he was fighting and they
needed this kind of shape in the trash
can
he's talking about or someone was in the
trash can at the time
kind of like that star trek the one with
the [ __ ] you know
that that which will survive now what
was the one [ __ ] you know where the
little
it's kind of like voyager probe it's
kind of like the veger pro well
uh no
must survive yeah sterilize like i said
yeah yeah
yeah well i remember that one yeah
vividly because uh mystery science
theater did one of their host segments
they parodied that yeah where they were
where they had one that came on there on
the satellite i love and it was called
moned
[Laughter]
and he was he kept like threatening to
wipe out mike and the bots because they
were imperfect
yeah yeah but they were able to like
fool him and he had to blow himself up
but yeah i can't remember what episode
that was but they
they did a lot of star trek parodies on
mystery science theater a lot
they did a mirror universe episode they
did all that but yeah
laughing but i don't know what she's
laughing at a possessed trash can
yeah it has to do with bombs and
if she lives in california now and she's
going the cali homeless are full of
sasquatch look at [ __ ]
yeah this is back in the 70s though they
were they were more rare back then
scared the [ __ ] out of us that's just
it's a very funny story yeah
it's kind of sad that he's i mean it's
not sad that he's still alive it's just
sad that he's still doing it but i don't
know maybe he's happy doing that
just living on the railroad tracks
didn't andre the giant fight the
greatest american hero
also yeah it probably did because uh
andre the giant played uh
played bigfoot i guess so yeah
andre the giant you remember him he was
in the princess bride also yeah
he died he did yeah he died fairly young
yeah we had giantism
yeah i kind of feel like a lot of people
that have that don't
live long all right so uh do we have
anything else that we need to discuss
that's it okay we've been gone it's like
50 minutes yeah i've got to wash my face
you know watch all the bacon it's making
the grease
out of your pores
you're lubricated yeah
it's just gonna run like this too you
know i mean just gotta like
just gotta like deal with it he's just
maybe
he's gonna walk through your house
leaving like a trail of grease like
behind him in the air
it comes and goes it comes and goes
i'm just not conscious i'm just [ __ ]
with you tom you don't sometimes i'll be
burning up man i'll be laying in bed and
i'm [ __ ] burning up i'll touch it
like and [ __ ]
i feel like i'm in like dog years like
i'm in dog heat
yeah oh man i'm burning up you got all
kinds of problems
yeah having all kinds of sexual problems
[Laughter]
now of course
man's gonna have sexual problems oh man
high testosterone levels yeah
i have to choke a [ __ ] yeah where is he
no i put him back over next to hh home
so they could like uh confer
no i don't want to hand out too many of
these uh btk
too many free btk impression
impersonations and [ __ ]
you got you all got to pay for them we
get super chat so
louis said tom's in heat
tom just spray on your brute and it's
all good it's it comes and goes it's not
it's not steady yeah tila says a horror
movie about a couple camping in search
of bigfoot
it's pretty good i can't recall the name
though fourth or down yeah i think it is
willow creek actually
that is actually a pretty good movie
that's not the only the only bigfoot
movie but
because they made boggy creek that was
yeah the body i don't know if you know
this i don't know if we mentioned this
on another
another show but buggy creek the legend
of buggy creek they kind of did an
investigation to figure out where that
came from it was
a story made up a long time ago probably
in the 30s
or 30s and it was made up evidently to
keep black people away
that's that's evidently what it was we
saw that on well dan bell went up there
yeah to arkansas right and they were
talking about the boggy creek creature
yeah uh legend ain't that some [ __ ]
white
there why do the 30s make up a monster
story
to keep black people away that's so
scooby-doo yeah like racist scooby-doo
yeah
i don't put it past the [ __ ] thinking
of the 20s though in the 30s
yeah that sounds like some [ __ ] there
that was like some [ __ ] whether it
worked or not it probably didn't work
i don't imagine it did i mean that seems
really dumb
it seems like the kind of dumb idea they
come up with but not not an idea that
we're
yeah it sounds like an idea that would
have
come they would have come up with in the
20s or the 30s centered around a general
store
yeah like a store owner where everybody
met
up in that area and maybe they would
like probably like post
things on the [ __ ] you know like on
the community billboard
right monster sightings and [ __ ] yeah
and then they
then they would all tell each other this
will keep the black people away
everybody knows how they're scared yeah
they're just hairy humanoids hair to
hair humanoids in the dark everybody
knows that
they're scared of the dog
it's probably where it's probably i mean
we're just saying like i said dan bell
did a thing where he went to arkansas
and he was talking about
the boggy creek movie which like i said
that was based on a real legend in
arkansas it was kind of like a bigfoot
and um or like skunk ape in florida yeah
and that's
what some of the locals told them anyway
that that's where the legend came from
originally it sounds very plausible
but yeah that that totally does sound
making up for the stories
yeah it's some little backwater like
arkansas yeah that i've heard the first
boggy creek
movie is good i saw it when i was a kid
but i don't really remember much about
it charles b pierce
um but the boggy creek 2
and the legend continues which i think
is actually the third boggy creek movie
was on mystery science theater and it's
so terrible but it is so delightful
that's like one of the best mst episodes
it's so so funny all right read off what
t said
where tila i got time today so i'll do
repo and legend of boggy creek today and
report back on wednesday
yeah you can report on sisters tom like
i said we i well
i don't know i was because i was gonna
do um like a recorded review of it but
you can talk about it a little bit on
the live show too if you want to or i
can
i don't know we'll we'll see how it goes
we'll see how it goes you're gonna see
boggy creek
that's funny wait the f well the first
one is decent
yeah um the sec the the second one which
is actually the third one which is
called then the legend continues
yeah is awful but if you see the mystery
science theater episode the mystery
science theater episode is
a [ __ ] riot yeah if you see the first
one
legend of boggy creek you might want to
see a mystery science theater version
of it first yeah because then they're
bagging on the movie too
as it's happening it is a very dated
movie
it's a homemade movie it's made pretty
well uh for
for the budget the guy who is
making this movie he puts himself in the
lead role
and his son as his right-hand man in
this [ __ ] movie
to hunt down bigfoot and of course he's
got two 70s hotties with it
or early 80s late 70s earlier because i
think the movie came out in the 80s
in the early 80s but it still looks kind
of so it's his [ __ ] middle-aged ass
with his [ __ ] young son who's a
teenager with these two [ __ ] hotties
in their 20s
all going out looking for bigfoot his
son's never got a damn shirt on through
the whole movie it's the craziest just
the craziest [ __ ] ever
and he's not like ripped or anything
yeah he's kind of scrawny
bones and then
it's just so [ __ ] implausible the
whole movie and then they end up hanging
out with a [ __ ] southern [ __ ] swap
rat dude who's
cletus who's like in the cletus no it's
not cleveland he's uh
crenshaw crenshaw that's right and
crenshaw actually is the highlight of
the movie he really is
that's my kind of woman right there i
kind of love you yeah yeah and he's just
a stereotypical
[ __ ] swamp rat all right he might be
playing himself he might never can't
even
think that he's playing you know can't
tell if it's real or if it's or
if it's exaggerated it's hard to tell
his
idea of a costume is just putting some
grease on his head to make him look well
he has like this big like rubber band
thing on his head
and he he has um overalls with a
shirt underneath but one of the under
overall things is undone
always and all he does is keep looking
at one of those those hides and goes boy
that's my kind of woman and and she
looks like linda ronstadt
a little bit like linda cross street and
linda ronstadt and the lead singer
journey
but crenshaw he's got the cha yeah he's
got like
he's just he's so [ __ ] funny and
there's another thing too that a couple
of times like they tell
other local stories about seeing the
baggy creek creature
and one of the stories um is pretty
gross because it has to do with this
dude that saw that was in the outhouse
yeah and then saw the body kirk teacher
and then like put his leg through the
outhouse and
like the grossest [ __ ] shade it's all
just like this gra
like this crass disgusting yeah like
lowbrow it's watchable on its own it is
it's watchable it's not bad um it's well
yeah it's bad
it's bad it's bad but it's it's
entertaining
uh but i think that the mst 3k or the
mystery science
theater uh version of it where you got
the robots making the fun of it at the
same time i think it's even that's one
of my favorite apps
actually because there's just so much
pretty funny for them to riff on
it's just it's delightful it's funny
because that we got to talk about boggy
creek of all things because the guy that
directed it and was in that movie
charles b pierce
he also directed the town that dreaded
sundown which is the movie that we're
going to do on their perspective
yeah i actually did like that it was
based on the phantom killer and actually
you know what they did a remake of that
in the early to mid 2000s i think and
that actually wasn't bad either
i might re-watch that too for the
further but in reality there was a
legend of boggy creek there was
and it was kind of a sasquatch legend
and that's what this movie is
about a man trying to investigate get
down the bottom of it
sasquatch but in reality the real legend
most likely was made up by the
townspeople to keep black people out of
town
that's what they said i mean of all the
things to come up with make up a monster
make up bigfoot like i said it's just
it's so scooby-doo
and then you have scooby-doo back there
crazy
that's like the stupidest thing i've
ever heard of well now i don't want to
say that because i've heard it's pretty
stupid because
but it's up there that's okay no it's
arkansas arkansas yeah
yeah that's something they would make up
in our oklahoma arkansas what's
different
all right so uh we will see you guys
again tomorrow
decent reviews on prime
it probably does it's right it probably
it's funny yeah it's funny it is
yeah uh yeah so we'll probably yes it's
1972.
yeah well wait a minute the first boggy
crew the first it's 1972. yeah that's
the decent one
yeah that's when we're talking about the
credential right no the one we're
talking about is
no okay the one we're talking about is
boggy creek two
and the legend continues oh that's the
one crankshaft yes okay
and that's actually it's actually the
third boggy creek movie because they
made a second one
and i think it didn't go anywhere so
they said we're going to make another
note yeah
we have to correct that t the 1972 was
the first one that's nothing
that's that's a good one that was pretty
good yeah the one we're talking about
with crenshaw and all the crazy [ __ ]
was the third one except it's called
two but it's called two yeah probably
like 78 or something like that it's
either i it you know what it might be
early 80s maybe early 80s right i'm not
it's
hard to say i think that i think it's
early 80s because i kind of feel like
she had like the lover boy kind of [ __ ]
yeah
out of the two i'd pick i'd pick foggy
creek the legend continues i picked that
one
to watch just because it's just but the
mst version
because it's just more bizarre
i mean the mst version is way better i
thought that was the first one but no
no no no i remember the first the first
one was when they were in those tents
right and he set up the damn [ __ ]
motion detectors
no that was the third one okay no yeah
that was the same one though the first
one
you might not have even seen them the
first one you just because you keep
saying wasn't it that was like that's
the same movie we've been talking okay
all right so i guess i never seen the
first one maybe not
i saw it a long time ago and i remember
being pretty good taylor said okay i
added one and two to the watch list i'm
gonna watch both i have a feeling i'm
gonna need a strong drink for viewing
purpose
yes i would recommend that yeah but i'd
actually rather watch i'd rather watch
repo genetic opera
than than than [ __ ] part one i don't
think they were
were they sequential uh
i think they were standalones yeah i
think they were too
because i think they kind of covered a
lot of the same ground yeah it's almost
like they were i think part
two part two and three were remakes of
part one
i don't even think i saw the actual
second one right
because so yeah because louis said
wasn't one called boggy creek the return
that might have been the second one that
didn't go anywhere i haven't seen that
one because like i said boggy creek 2
and the legend continues i think it's
actually the third one the t they
weren't real movies
the dude that stars in these directed
them
and produced them made them for a
local audience yeah for other arkansas
people other people in arkansas
all right he was happy to get it to play
in like four or five theaters
they weren't bad but he was trying to
show those
california boys over and over in over
over in hollywood that
that arkansas could make movies all
right
i'm not sure he really accomplished that
yeah
well i mean he did make movies i'll give
him that he did make movies
i think they probably did make some
money but
i believe in my heart watching it
the true motive was to get in young
women's pants
that's what i think well isn't that the
only reason that dudes do anything
that's probably why they did it over
there in hollywood anyway
i mean to get in people's pants because
it
i'm watching and why would this dude
spend his money on this and then you see
the girls he's working with he goes yeah
he's cracking that
he's cracking us or attempting to go
or he's trying to get his son to crack
him
it makes you wonder what the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was about they're not
bad but they're they're bad but they're
they're watchable and and
it is funny when you think about when
you're watching the star of this thing
and realizing that
that he's making this movie on his own
yeah and it and it kind of makes it
enjoyable
because most of the movie is about how
[ __ ] smart he is
yeah because of course he wrote himself
like he's the one that knows everything
yeah
is how attractive he is how all these
women love him
it's just [ __ ] funny you know how
he's only only gonna be the only guy
that can find bigfoot
or his son maybe might find bigfoot it's
just funny man
it's funny it's it's a middle-aged
male's
it's a it's unsophisticated
70s and 80s fantasy of a middle-aged man
yeah that's what this [ __ ] movie is
that psycho analyzed it as that
which i there were a lot of like low
budget movies like that and those are
usually like really funny to watch
yeah like especially dudes that wrote
themselves into the
main roles and they're like star and in
a row and then the whole like movie is
just about how awesome and right about
everything exactly exactly
so so funny well it's like so
transparent that it's really really
funny
like that dude who always uh casts
himself as jesus
or an alien from yeah what's that dude's
name god damn it how he's attacking i
know he's talking about marvel
and how all the women love him no matter
what he looks like
yeah which i don't understand that
[ __ ] you know yeah that dude he's
made like four or five movies
yeah and he's always saw solving the
world's problems
yeah i mean leaving the planet it's a
massive yeah
ego thing but those are really funny to
watch i think i think he's talked about
a few of them on [ __ ] case cinema
yeah you know what i mean and he's just
a very
subpar looking man with these [ __ ]
like
ultra hot [ __ ] chicks for hire who
just love him
in this movie he's ridiculous man
it is it's hilarious dom the bomb says
what's repo about
it's um repo is good yeah repo the
genetic opera
it's a musical it's a musical yeah and
it's about
it's kind of like a it's like a
post-apocalyptic future kind of
in a future when corporations and
run everything and it's kind of like an
ogallopoly i guess you could say
and it's about a guy who's a grave
digger
and what he does is digs up dead bodies
to extract
a chemical from the pituitary glands of
the dead
and from that hormone they make a drug
called xydrate
and xydrate is a [ __ ] drug that you
can inject into your body and and it
will make
cosmetic surgery and transplants that
will make it painless and you'll heal up
a lot faster
so there's this company out there that
needs xi
and they will sell you body
modifications on loan
high-tech body modifications and if you
don't pay for them
they have special guys called repo men
that hunt you down and cut those [ __ ]
modifications out of you without
anesthesia while you're live
and that's all part of this movie yeah i
should know too because i think we were
when we were talking about before when
we talked about the songs i decided
anatomy
and actually they played that at the
halfway to halloween party yeah they
play it
paris hilton sings it and she does a
good job yeah she doesn't sing the whole
thing but she's on it yeah
uh but yeah they actually did play that
but if you go on youtube
just look up just search zydrate anatomy
it's a song
you can listen to it and that'll give
you a that'll give you a sneak peek into
what that movie's about that's a good
song
yeah that's a good flick as well i like
it better than i like it better than um
uh what do you call it rocky horror i
like it better than rocky horror
it's more modern and it's more gothic
industrial it's got
yeah it's a lot newer not better music
it's newer music
real good visuals it's real goffed out
got
all different kinds of like gothic
imagery you know [ __ ] cyber goth and
[ __ ]
retro [ __ ] kind of victorian style
stuff and then there's medical themes
and
grave robbing themes where there's kind
of almost like medieval looking people
in it
it's pretty neat yeah it's dead bodies
it's pretty fun it's a horror movie
yeah kind of the horror horror musical
right sure
all right so uh i guess we've been going
for over an hour
so we'll wrap it up for today and we'll
be back tomorrow probably talking about
another
movie i haven't decided which one yet
but we'll we'll figure it out when we
get to it
but uh as always thanks for dropping by
have a good
rest of your weekend and we will see you
tomorrow
bye